There is currently a Senator Kennedy in the Senate
and he's actually named John Kennedy, but he's a
Republican. He is not related to the well-known
Kennedys of of Democratic Party fame. And in the
wake of multiple major mass shootings in the last
week, Senator Kennedy has been doing the rounds
to equate guns to cars, insisting that, listen,
we don't ban cars because sometimes people die
in car accidents. We don't ban cars because
sometimes people drive drunk. And this could
not be a sillier analogy. And we're going to talk
about why in a moment. But understand that at a at
a top level, even comparing cars and guns is
fraught because of their intended purposes.
Cars were never designed to kill
people or animals or maim them.
Yes, a car can be misused as a weapon, but it
wasn't invented for that. Guns were invented
to kill or maim people or animals and sometimes
to threaten people with the fear of doing that.
Yes, guns can be used for target practice.
That's not what they were invented for.
Most people don't own guns merely for target
practice. Most car related deaths are accidents.
Most gun related deaths are deliberate homicides
and suicides. There are gun accidents as well. OK,
so the comparison at a base level makes no
sense. Senator John Kennedy and some others
don't care or don't know. Here is John Kennedy at
a congressional hearing earlier this week saying
we have lots of drunk driving deaths.
We don't ban sober drivers from driving.
But I do think we ought to
keep this in perspective.
What has happened in the last few days, what's
happened in the last years is, of course, tragic.
And I'm not I'm not trying to
perfectly equate these two, but.
We have a lot of drunk drivers in
America that kill a lot of people.
We are well to try to combat that, too.
But I think what many folks on my side of
the aisle are saying is that the answer
is not to get rid of all sober drivers.
The answers to concentrate on the problem,
I guess Senator Kennedy really liked this
analogy because then he appeared on Fox News
and made a similar car related analogy to guns
during an interview with Fox and Friends
host Brian Kilmeade yesterday morning.
But you don't stop drunk drivers getting rid
of all sober drivers, which is what many of my
Democratic friends want to do with respect to the
Second Amendment and my judgment. We do not need
more gun control. We need more idiot control.
So part of the problem with saying that this
is about idiot control, so therefore don't do
anything about guns is that it's too easy for
idiots in the U.S. to get guns in the first place
and there's too many idiots in the United States.
But the analogy to vehicles is really a terrible
one because we already regulate vehicles
way more than we regulate getting guns.
John Kennedy says let's not go crazy
with cars like some want to do with guns because
that would be bad. Actually, we do much more with
drivers and vehicles already to get a driver's
license in the first place. In most states,
you need to pass a written test, have a certain
number of practice hours, pass a driving test,
renew the license periodically. Sometimes that
includes an eye exam. If you get too many tickets,
you lose your license. If you don't pay tickets,
you can lose your license. In most states,
the car has to be insured. In most states you
need to have the car inspected yearly for safety.
Depending on the age of the car, there would be an
emissions test to see if it's roadworthy based on
modern emission standards. If you drive drunk,
you can use your license or even go to prison.
It's not. You know, no one is suggesting. He
says, let's not do with cars what we do with what
Democrats want to do with guns. In reality, it's
Republicans who don't even want to do with guns,
what we already do with cars and drivers. I have
many Democratic and left leaning friends who own
firearms. They all want universal background
checks, mandatory waiting period to get a gun
limits on certain types of weapons, but arguably,
just as importantly, limits on certain ammunition
purchases, mandatory relicensing and
testing and mandatory gun insurance.
We have a Second Amendment. I'm not disputing
that. None of my left leaning gun owner friends
are disputing that. What we're disputing is that
we don't even make it as difficult to get a gun
as we make it to get a driver's license. And
that doesn't make any sense whatsoever. And a
lot of this stuff is actually not controversial.
Universal background checks. You know, it ebbs and
flows over time, but it's overwhelmingly popular
with the American people. In the wake of the Sandy
Hook shooting, it was like eighty eight to 90
percent support. Republicans just said no, it was
a nonstarter with Republicans. A lot of this isn't
controversial with the American people. And it is
a designed controversy by the NRA and other groups
because they just want to sell guns. Always the
threat of someone taking your gun is a great way
to get people to go and buy guns before they make
them illegal. Right. This is this is how the NRA
sells guns. And from the standpoint of elections,
these are often for the right great issues for
raising money. So terrible analogy. Cars and
guns doesn't make any sense. Friday, March 26th,
one day membership special. We're almost there.
We had a pretty, pretty, pretty poor month in
February from the standpoint of membership's,
a lot of cancelations because of what's going
on economically. So we're doing a vaccine themed
membership blowout on Friday. If you want to get
the instructions for how to take advantage of it,
just get on my mailing list at Join Pakman
Dotcom Friday morning. You'll get an email and
you'll be able to sign up at a huge
discount. It's a beautiful thing.